all right sean is with us in New York
City Sean welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show well Dave thanks for having me it's
a true pleasure to speak with you
you too sir thanks for being on a
millionaire so what is your net worth
sir somewhere around four million okay
very cool how old are you 46 Wow young
one all right good
and what's the money invested in a
majority of it is in my business the
rest is in real estate and some in cash
okay
real estate small business and cash most
of it there all right
and your average work income and your
working lifetime uh 225 200 to 225
thousand I would say okay very cool very
good washing cars washing cars you know
a car business I have a little detailing
car wash business just I do since I was
a seventeen years old how many team
members team members right now 17 okay
Wow substantial then very cool yeah
congratulations that's fine you thank
you so how do you how do you say you've
become worth four million dollars at
forty six or somebody says how do you
did you do that
what do you tell stable oil to myself
and my my company my team members our
average team members been here give or
take ten years I never guided off the
path of you know continuing to do what
I've been doing over the last thirty
years give or take you know your word
intentional be intentional about what
you're doing every day day in day out
and not veering off that path is
extremely important how much debt do you
have now
well because of you fortunately just my
house personally the business has very
little down to its last let's just call
it a very small bit I picked up the
Total Money Makeover last year and and
you know fortunately even though getting
to the point that I got to your help
still was needed did you inherit money
none
how many new cars have you bought in
your life none I use Ford dealer what
would you pay for your last pair of blue
jeans probably $80 okay cool man your
great American success story I love
small business guys out there getting it
done
thank you Shawn thanks for sharing the
numbers millionaire hour on the Dave
Ramsey show